About 10 miles outside China’s
eleventh-largest city lies a graveyard.
Its occupants aren’t human. Nor are they
dead, though they have seen better days.
These hundreds and hundreds of little
white rectangles are cars. Electric cars.
…Victims of China’s incredibly rapid
and unparalleled automotive revolution.
When this Changan Eado debuted in 2015
with a range of just over 120-miles and
a top speed of less than 90 miles an hour,
it was among the country’s best-selling EVs.
At the time, China exported only about 375,000
cars a year, less than India or the United
States, and a tiny fraction of Japan or Germany.
For the next five years, it
made only modest progress.
Then, while the rest of the world was
stuck indoors, China leaped ahead of India,
followed by the U.S., and is on track to beat
both Germany and Japan to become #1 this year.
Today, the Changan Eado is but a forgotten
relic – an iPod – functional yet worthless.
In its place, Chinese drivers have
hundreds of models to choose from.
There’s the BYD Han – a Tesla Model S in
form and function for nearly half the price.
There’s the Wuling Bingo – an innovative hatchback
equipped with a built-in inflatable mattress.
There’s the best-selling Hongguang Mini –
a $5,000 4-seat, street-legal micro-car.
And for those decidedly not on a budget,
the $700,000 Rolls-Royce of China:
the Hongqi L5 – proudly used
by none other than Xi Jinping.
How did China go from 500 EVs on the
streets of Shanghai in 2011 to being
the undisputed leader in electric cars today?
Sponsored by Ground News – the platform
where you can easily compare news sources,
protect against media bias,
and stay on top of headlines.
This is what China’s most populous
city looked like in April 2000.
You’ll notice lots of bikes, quite
a few scooters, and even some buses.
What you don’t see a lot of are cars.
Just four million were on the road
for a population of 1.3 billion – a
number surpassed by the United
States somewhere around 1910.
But by 2005, car ownership had more than
tripled and its streets looked like this.
Suddenly, China had an oil problem.
The basic challenge can be
boiled down to just two numbers:
China consumes upwards of 13% of the
world’s oil yet is home to a mere 1.5%.
The rest it mainly imports from the Middle East.
Not only does this make it incredibly dependent
on a small handful of countries, but because the
vast majority of this oil arrives on tankers, it
also depends on the generosity of the U.S. Navy
to patrol these waters, not to mention the
goodwill of every nation along this route.
…Needless to say: not ideal.
China also had a pollution problem.
To this day more of its citizens die of
pollution each year than live in Hawaii.
That’s well over 4,000 deaths on the average day.
While the country is no stranger to
environmental destruction, these costs
are typically borne disproportionately
by the less socioeconomically advantaged.
In other words, nickel mines, coal plants,
and mega-dams are built where
residents are powerless to stop them.
Air pollution, by contrast, is often worse in
its most populous and wealthy coastal cities.
According to one estimate, 38%
of the Chinese population lives
in an area where the average air quality
would be deemed “unhealthy” by the EPA.
Many of 21st Century China’s largest
protests have revolved around air pollution.
Enter: electric vehicles.
Beijing calculated that nearly
a third of its smog was caused
by cars. And that even if all its
electricity were sourced from coal,
EVs would still generate fewer emissions
than internal combustion engines.
For years, China had been
trying to catch up to German
and Japanese automakers by forcing
them to work with local companies.
Except, rather than stealing from their foreign
counterparts – as is often imagined –
Chinese engineers became dependent on them.
Eventually, the Chinese government
realized it simply wasn’t going to win.
So, it decided to start a new race. One
in which its competitors’ head start was
actually a disadvantage – Mercedes
and Toyota and Ford were complacent.
Unlike traditional cars, EVs were
perfectly compatible with China’s economy.
Where internal combustion engines
rely on small amounts of high-skill,
high-cost labor, EVs rely on relatively
larger amounts of low-skill, low-cost labor.
By value, an electric car is essentially
a battery wrapped in some packaging.
And batteries – to grossly
oversimplify – are commodities.
Like any commodity, the cost would
inevitably go down with scale.
The challenge was sustaining these
companies until they reached profitability.
China’s solution was to just buy from them.
After the 2008 financial crisis,
Chinese cities helped stimulate
the economy by buying loads and
loads of electric buses and taxis.
By 2014, Shenzhen had more than 1,200. Three years
later, all 17,000 of its buses were electric.
Then came the subsidies. Billions
and billions worth of subsidies.
At one point, buyers could save as
much as $16,000 U.S. Dollars per EV.
But although the Chinese government may have
handed out as much as a hundred billion dollars,
these subsidies weren’t the biggest
reason people bought electric cars.
In a 2016 survey, 52% of respondents said they
would not have purchased their
EV if not for its license plate.
Most Chinese cities distribute new license plates
by lottery, auction, or both. In 2016, your odds
of winning the Beijing lottery were one in 667.
In Shanghai, plates can sell for $10,000 or more.
And even with plates, you may only be
allowed to drive on certain days of the week.
Buy an EV, on the other hand, and you’ll
automatically receive a special green license
plate – no lottery or auction necessary. Green
plates are China’s American Express Platinum – a
mass-market golden ticket to drive on any day
of the week and, in some places, park for free.
Unsurprisingly, these policies
worked. A little too well.
The country became saturated with
hundreds of nearly identical brands.
It wasn’t so much that China
was propping-up uncompetitive
companies as hundreds of cities were each
propping-up their uncompetitive companies.
It was as if Seattle, Minneapolis, Houston, and
Pittsburg each had its own Tesla competitor.
Rather than let the best EV win,
each region was too dependent on its
“local champion” to allow its failure.
On one hand, this unusually saturated market
means Chinese consumers have more
choices than any other country.
Take a look, for instance, at EV sales in America.
At first glance, this may look
like success. But if we remove
the largest company, you can see that EVs
haven’t really grown over time. Tesla has.
Americans effectively have four models
from one major brand to choose from.
By contrast, Chinese companies released
107 new models last year alone – from
ultra-affordable “mini EVs” to
ones where you can quickly swap
out your battery at one of thousands of
stations instead of waiting for a charge.
On the other hand, five hundred companies is just
too many – even for a country as large as China.
So, around 2016, the Communist Party
did something uncharacteristic:
it let Capitalism take the wheel.
Subsidies have been slowly phased out and
local governments prohibited from
favoring one company over another.
At the same time, Beijing dropped a
nuclear bomb on the Chinese auto industry.
After decades of carefully
nurturing local companies,
the Chinese government rolled out the
red carpet for a foreign competitor.
For the first time ever, Tesla was
given permission to build its 9 million
square foot Shanghai factory without
working with a joint Chinese partner.
And that’s not all.
Inspired by California, Beijing instituted
a credit system. Every automaker is now
required to sell a certain number of EVs
for each conventional car it produces.
Those who fall short must make up the difference
by purchasing credits from their competitors.
Since Tesla only produces EVs, it earned
nearly $1.6 billion from selling credits in
2020 alone. Without this revenue, the company
would’ve lost $859 million overall that year.
One could argue that Tesla
was the largest beneficiary of
Chinese state involvement in the entire industry.
Protectionism? Sure, for an American company.
Chinese companies were suddenly on
their own. Meanwhile, here was this
800-pound gorilla with a stronger
brand than all the rest combined.
To make matters worse, Tesla,
still on the high-end, lowered the cost of
its two most popular models by 6 and 13%.
What happened next was an all-out price war.
In the space of just a few short years, something
like 80% of China’s EV companies collapsed.
NIO, one of its largest, lost
$131,000 for every car it sold.
But this consolidation – painful as it
was – had the effect Beijing intended.
Those that survived have thrived.
Today, about 40% of new car
sales in China are electric.
Of them, one Chinese company –
BYD – sells more than the 2nd,
3rd, 4th, 5th, 6th, and 7th-place brands combined.
It’s on track to sell more electric cars than
Volkswagen will sell cars
– of any kind – this year.
Tesla is the only foreign carmaker not in decline.
The days of Ford, Honda, and BMW
dominating the Chinese market are
over and the tide is beginning to
flow in the opposite direction.
Chinese cars can now be found in Mexico,
Saudi Arabia, Belgium, the U.K., Chile,
and Australia – to name just a few.
Meanwhile, at a time when China
is embracing the free market,
it’s now America’s turn to
resort to protectionism.
Previously, nearly every EV buyer in
America could receive a $7,500 tax credit.
Now, only cars whose batteries were produced in
North America and whose minerals were
processed by a U.S. ally are eligible.
America is trying to out China China.
To impose the same restrictions
it once criticized Beijing for.
But will it work?
First, consider demand.
In a recent survey, the average
American said they would need
a range of over 500 miles to consider
buying an EV – the most of any country.
Chinese consumers had the lowest
expectations – about half as many.
It makes sense: China has fast and
efficient high-speed trains for
longer journeys. For Americans,
car ownership is a way of life.
Most Chinese consumers are buying their first-ever
car. They value its interface as much
as, if not more than its performance.
In other words, Chinese and
American consumers are different.
Secondly, there’s supply.
The Chinese government didn’t attempt to manifest
a battery industry out of thin air – it
subsidized those that already existed.
BYD – the country’s largest EV brand,
as you’ll recall – began, in fact,
as a battery maker. It successfully produced phone
batteries for years before refocusing on cars.
America doesn’t have those companies to
subsidize. It’s effectively starting from scratch.
Finally, the most effective Chinese policies
were coercive. A Civil War would break out
before the United States would restrict the
days of the week on which you can drive.
All of this suggests America
has a tough road ahead.
…Nevermind that it’s starting this
race about 15-20 years too late.
As of today, just 25 models of cars are
eligible for the new $7,500 federal tax credit.
The other 70% of all electric, hydrogen, and
hybrid cars sold in America are ineligible.
Biden’s Inflation Reduction Act is
an attempt to have it both ways:
to increase the number of EVs on America’s roads
while simultaneously decreasing China’s dominance.
But the reality is: China has spent
decades building up its supply chain.
Nearly every electric car company in
the world depends on its batteries.
It refines over half of the world’s lithium and
three-quarters of the world’s nickel and cobalt.
A world without China is, at least
for now – a world without EVs.
Nearly 40% of EVs in America are
registered in a single state:
California. And one of the reasons for this
incredible polarization is their media coverage.
In choosing what and, perhaps more
importantly, what not to include,
journalists have no choice but to introduce
bias. And although we may be aware of this bias,
it’s often invisible until compared, side-by-side,
with other sources covering the same story –
something few of us have the time or energy to do.
Enter today’s sponsor, Ground News.
Take this story about Ford layoffs amid the
EV transition. With Ground News, we can see
that of these 24 sources, 20% are Left-leaning
and 50% Right-leaning. We can also see how each
one is covering this same story differently,
revealing its hidden narrative underneath.
For example, notice how three out of four
Left-leaning publications mention these
are white-collar jobs, whereas eight out of
ten Right-leaning publications omit this fact
entirely. We can even click on one of these
sources and see where it gets its funding.
Ground News makes being an informed consumer
of the news easy, with Android and iOS apps,
including – my personal favorite – widgets for
your home screen and even browser extensions.
For a limited time, get 30% off your
subscription by clicking the link on
screen or in the description. Thanks to
Ground News for sponsoring this video.